okay once again one point and we're
going to get into really getting to
what's going to become the foundation of
a lot of the moves you're going to learn
in this course
take your poi and put it in your your
left hand and face me I'm gonna mirror
you so you're like this I'm like this
and just get it spinning forwards you're
spinning towards me I'm spinning towards
you so you've got it going past your
left foot awesome
forward circles so I could hit you in
the foot then you can stop come to the
other side with your arm and spin it on
your right side and again make sure it's
going forwards so it's coming down in
front of you and it hit you to hit you
in the foot I want you just get a
feeling of each side so you can stop it
first and then once you realize okay
this is forwards on the left side and
this is for it's on the right side just
let it cross back and cross over and
cross your cross
so again if you imagine you're standing
on the train tracks you're switching
from one track you're on one track and
you switch over to the other track now I
want you to notice I'm gonna switch and
I'm going to we're gonna flock if here
you're going forward your left hand if
you turn and look at it well it's going
clockwise correct yeah it's gone so for
me this is going clockwise
okay so then we switch over and now it's
going forward but at your right shoulder
if you turn to look at that which oh
well now it seems to be going
counterclockwise but the poise not
changing directions is it it's just it's
like you're stepping through and looking
at it from the other side
so from this side it's going
counterclockwise
relative to you and on this side it's
going clockwise relative to you
so I just want you get used to that
clockwise counterclockwise clockwise
counterclockwise clockwise
counterclockwise I'm going to switch and
miR you again
so what you want to do is just be able
to relax into this movement so see if
you can you just get a cross inside the
side now and then notice the rest of
your body so in the beginning people
often they're just here in their arm and
that can be a bit stiff so as this right
off to normal but as it works start to
breathe really I mean I mean deep
breathe like really and that'll let your
health will help your body to relax and
then you'll naturally the movement will
start being from the whole body so your
weight is pivoting from foot to foot
your hips are turning your shoulders are
moving and the movements coming from a
swaying of the entire body rather than
just the arm
they're both ultimately okay there's
nothing wrong with standing still and
just using your arm it can just be
really nice to have it all come from the
whole body which will in the long run be
much better for lending itself the turns
and dance then you just I want you to
explore I mean you can see you can cross
really wide right you see how big you
can make it and if right now it's
awkward that's fine it'll be awkward at
first you'll get better with practice
you can reach up to the ceiling so you
can cross back and forth really high or
you can reach to the ground cross back
and forth right at your feet or you can
see how close you can bring your hand to
you or you can see how far you can reach
in front so once your left hand is used
to that do it with your right hand same
thing once you've got a crossing cross
back and forth relax into it and play
high and play low and play wide and play
narrow and play slow and fur and close
and turning a lot and not running at all
and this will get you ready and it's fun
so
now play with that and then we're gonna
come back and run across the play
backwards